John can you go into some more detail on
this blackmail theme of how Bush might
be subject to blackmail because of his
involvement in the CIA and in other
activities during the Reagan
administration what would be an example
of this and how would such blackmail
work well let's go into the most obvious
case that we know of the one that we
have the best documented so far and this
is this black eagle thing that was
started in an 82 essentially in a
reversal of roles the CI is actually
created to give the White House and the
executive plausible deniability so they
can keep clean and if the CI does
something wrong they can you know what
we didn't know about it and they can
fire the CIA's director William Casey
reversed this policy and it was actually
quite clever in in retrospect in
iran-contra thing he initiated the
iran-contra thing but he managed to have
Ronald Reagan in the White House take
the heat for it he ran it through Oliver
North so it became a political thing
whereas the CIA was clearly under the
thumb of the Congress or should have
been or legally was but he also this
black eagle operation of delivering arms
to the to the Contras he got George Bush
to front for that to use the vice
president's office to front for that and
Bush was a very activist vice president
running this this this thing they had on
anti-terrorism supposedly which is of
course 1980s were doublespeak for you
know running terrorist activities
smuggling arms and through that
operation they began to work through
Panama and the planes flying through
Panama and Noriega gave them access to
the air strips that they needed and
immediately began working the other end
of the line through the Medellin using
the same black eagle planes to fly drugs
up here into the United States and Bush
was his office was was shutting was
running this thing now obviously they
tried to maintain what I thought was a
very thin
implausible deniability of having Don
Gregg running the thing right out of
George Bush's office with his assistant
what's his name Samuel Watson and then
Felix Rodriguez down in El Salvador and
then a network that went throughout
planes flying throughout southern air
transport involved their own airplanes
involved and and yet
the the only deniability was Greg saying
well I never told the vice president
about all of these things which is
utterly impossible it is not within the
realm of human with unless the person
were a Ronald Reagan and even then he
would have had to have known what what
Gregg was doing can you give us a little
background on Gregg the fact that he and
Bush had been together in the CIA
buddies for a long time yeah Greg with
uh not original I think he came in to
the CIA and 51 a graduate of Williams
college at the height you know that was
getting into the the McCarthy era the
height of conservativism the Korean War
a very very conservative era and and he
joined and and had what you know was
ultimately tremendously successful
career in fact I thought that Bush would
wind up appointing him as a CI director
and instead he's gone with William
Webster the guy had to do with the
destabilization of Cuba in the 60s he
wound up in Vietnam in Military Region 3
in 1970 and that's the you know where I
was except I didn't overlap with him but
I got there just after he had left so
there were a lot of people were talking
about him and about Felix Rodriguez who
was one of his favored operatives and in
the height of the Phoenix program and
Shockley was his boss wasn't he and
Shaklee was the boss so you see the same
group moving in with George Bush then in
the basement of the White House Y next
door to Oliver North - Shaklee Shaklee
wasn't yeah - Shockley who had been
squeezed up but then the fact I was
still in operation involved in a lot of
well I'm sure the old boy thing works so
that he was in contact with them but
don't ever forget that these people
fight a lot there they are are as bad as
people in the peace movement about well
literally you remember when Black Eagle
eventually fell apart and then the the
enterprise kind of became apart it
Oliver North and Felix Rodriguez were at
each other's throats and he's two very
volatile unstable dangerous men who
couldn't get along you remember the the
incident that's cited in the foreign
policy fall 88 issue that broke black
eagle was when the CIA operatives it
doesn't name them and Israeli operatives
drew their pistols on each other this
was nineteen eighty five eighty five and
they were about to start blasting each
other away and the senior head said
everybody cool they just you know slowed
down and prevailed and got everybody put
their guns back and at the same time the
Pollard case was breaking and the US was
going to prosecute the powers in Israel
didn't appreciate that so it was on for
Israel and against the United States and
cannon glorify something may argue
through with it what you know there's so
much of this material yeah I'm a bit
confused now Oliver North
office was next door to George Bush and
Donald Gregg's in the bottom of the
White House that I understand it now
were they working together or as I've
heard some people say they actually had
two separate arms running and drug
smuggling operations going or were they
separate but coordinated well you know
they have done everything they could up
the skate if you will and confuse the
issue north admitted that he was he met
with bush on many occasions but he
minimized the cooperation the the way I
see it is there are a number of
different offices and people did have
different roles to play and there were
different power lines working and don't
ever forget that there is a just a norm
of every presidency since I've been
anyway is a lot of intense
competitiveness
I mean people they're really ruthless
everybody's jockeying for position
endlessly inside the White House and the
vice president's office if he has any
power so so North was definitely part of
the same machinery he was definitely
cooperating with George Bush as as Bush
was cooperating with Casey but at the
same time North was definitely beating
his own drum and and Tooting his own
horn and flying around the world
grandstanding and settings they were not
what you know it was not a disciplined
unit like one CIA office would be or one
Marine Division would be or one one of
your Navy ships would be and these are a
lot of competing people who are in the
same ideology the same administration
and and moving in the same direction
what's a naval in touch the way that the
Rolling Stone told this story in their
November third essay on this dirty
secrets of George Bush the Black Eagle
operation that Bush Rodriguez and Gregg
were running was coming apart because of
this rupture with the Israelis and also
because they found out Noriega was
running so many drugs that this was
threatening the integrity of the
operation so north began this other
Enterprise literally called the
enterprise with Richard Secord and Hakim
and these people to bring arms down to
the Contras
but Secord had trouble getting it off so
that Felix Rodriguez began another
operation and once Secord got his going
they shut down the operation with
Rodriguez's Cuban friends who'd lost a
lot of money in this and we're very
angry and this began the tension between
Rodriguez and bush and the Secord North
group and eventually the tensions there
sort of exploded and Bush was the guy
supposedly trying to hold everything
together that when these other guys
North and Rodriguez were each other's
throats Bush was the guy that had to
smooth things over so again he played a
major role in
carried out these operations according
at least of these this Rolling Stone
story it seemed fairly well documented
no I the way the way you describe it is
the way I have I have read it myself
very much that in fact the one the
original outfit they had built this
giant warehouse called the arm
supermarket and stocked it with arms
which was supposed to be bought by the
Contras with US taxpayers dollars of the
private enterprise dollars and and at
the time that that North pulled away
from that that enterprise to start the
enterprise they had that thing stocked
with 18 million dollars worth of arms
now you know arms is a cash for business
and this cash had to come from the
Medellin Colombian cocaine cartel so
there was drug money that they had been
working with that it stocked this
warehouse counting on selling the arms
to the to the enterprise smally to that
and then north did break away at the
point where he saw that thing apparently
as getting out of control as being too
explosive net was not don't anyone
misunderstand that he was morally
troubled by working with people who were
smuggling drugs he had known for years
these people were smuggling drugs but as
you noted the volume of it was getting
so high that he saw on an earthquake
coming and actually moved there also was
undoubtedly a part of his ego power-play
power struggle at the level of him in
Rodriquez at the level perhaps of him
and a Gregg during this whole time
George Bush was supervisor he was
control of the drug anti-drug program in
the United States not just the
propaganda bit you know just say no but
great operand and very expensive
operation to interdict drugs and to keep
them from coming into the United States
so it was a perfect circle not only from
the propaganda point of view
bush could be said to be the guy who is
keeping it from coming in but on the
covert aspect he could make sure that
this stuff came in undetected and yet
one of these stories came out during the
election campaign when I left for Europe
on August 217 during the Republican
convention Dukakis was ten or fifteen
points ahead Bush had just nominated
Quayle chosen Quayle as vice president
that looked like it was going to be a
self-destruct operation and when I came
back a month later Bush was ten points
ahead what do you make of this how do
you analyze Bush's turning things around
and winning the presidency what was
involved in is well one just quick
observation is there's a false foot some
false polling in the summer after the
Democratic convention the Democrats
always look better they've gotten a lot
of publicity and then a month later
after the Republican convention they
have a surge back and so it's sometime
about the 1st of September where the
polls I think I forget the figure but
it's something like 9 times out of 10
the one who is leading on the 1st of
September wins
so it's stabilized by the end of August
and in fact by the end of August Bush
was ahead again the Quayle thing was a
heavy hit of Bush it one might call it a
major blunder but since he succeeded we
all reflected on that a lot his choice
of Quayle as I see it was twofold he had
to pick someone who would make him look
like a giant and that was not easy to do
if he picked a Bob Dole for example
someone who knew knew more and had a
stronger personality he would have all
kinds of problems
he also in my opinion and this is an
analysts opinion you know this is not
based on any hard quotes or anything
very subjective but he also had to pick
someone who was bought into the
iran-contra scandal and Quayle was he
was the senator from Indiana and
Indiana's the state that John Hall
you know came from who was the man who
had the ranch in Costa Rica from which
all the drug smuggling in the arms you
know from the southern side of the
contra thing had been run and it turns
out as we dug up in August and found out
it that this young man working for quail
introduced halt to Oliver North
originally and that young man's name was
Robert Owens and so Quayle Owens was
working for quail when he that induced
John Howe oh yes when he introduced John
Holt Oliver North and gave them that
whole option which evolved into the
enterprise and and the whole scandal for
that's incredible the whole
interconnections all of this yes enter
can even Quayle I mean this is see
amazing now what to go back this is a
very complicated thing but I think we
can sort it out
I don't think Bush dared to have someone
in office who was clean of the
iran-contra thing like dole who could
benefit from an impeachment so he needed
someone that would be tainted enough
with the iran-contra that they would be
forced to resign at the same time they
would be impeached with him who could
not possibly benefit from his
impeachment he needed to create a
situation correct himself where the
establishment couldn't shunt him aside
and put in a strong figure like door or
Howard Baker who would be very
acceptable to the public and to the
establishment right and that's that's
where I work well that's where Quayle
came and that Barbara Honegger who is
not the world's greatest analyst but she
certainly has a lot of fire and
imagination and she coined the phrase
that he was Quayle was Bush's
impeachment insurance